[Music]
we've been using a high-speed camera
to film hydrogen balloons exploding
[Music]
[Laughter]
i like you new brady and neil thought it
might be fun
to try and add a piece of metallic
lithium to 7up
long ago 7up used to contain lithium
salts
the reaction of sodium with water is
terribly well known
we've done it lots of times on our
videos the orange sodium flame
holy crap oh it's on your camera i love
boron boron
is an interesting element we could make
hundreds of youtube videos about
nitrogen and still not tell you
everything
the oxygen molecule o2 has
unpaired electrons
and there she blows
you can see in the tube here is actually
the result or the aim of our chemical
reaction today because we wanted to make
some sulfur
pretty cool it's really good it's um
kind of i don't know
a sort of really pale gold color oh yeah
it's very warm here today and
the season's melted so we're just going
to try and
freeze it again now some of you may have
seen
on youtube there are videos that pretend
to be huge explosions of francine
berkelium which i assume was named after
the place of its discovery which was
berkeley this is a vial of americium 241
which is one of the isotopes of
americium potassium
metal is very reactive one of my
colleagues who used to work with it
described it as evil
calcium is the third element in group
two on the periodic table
so here we have some calcium tunings
magnesium
is one of the lightest elements it's
right at the beginning of the periodic
table
there's a dome-shaped device and it's
fabricated from beryllium metal
and so we've come here because there's a
really interesting exhibit
relevant to the work of lawrence the
person after whom
the element lorenzium was named after
californium is another
element which was first prepared the
berkeley labs in california it's got
quite a few military applications
usually involving the word nuclear
and it can exist as neptunium-4
neptunium-5 or neptunium-6
they're probably far more molecules that
contain carbon
than any other element and you can see
that the phosphorus is oxidized in the
air
and it's taken some of the paper with it
to generate a nice pea
for phosphorus it is said that people
get off the bus
when selenium chemists get on
chlorine is an element that many people
have heard of
incredibly reactive incredibly poisonous
so this is bromine it's a small sample
about two or three grams they're not
many elements that are actually liquid
so in the bottom here we see neon and
this is again this is a small
glass discharge tube helium is the
second element
on the periodic table there are 115 more
videos to watch
we're in the library of the royal
society
looking at letters about radon we always
think of these
scientists in the past as being saints
and here he is sitting in his office
thinking
he i've made my competitor feel
uncomfortable
aluminium is a surprisingly abundant
element we're never going to run out of
aluminium this is a piece of
polycrystalline silicon
it's a really quite fantastic element
terbium was eventually discovered or
eventually isolated by the chemist
mossanda in 1843.
it was isolated from an earth called
itria which was
originated in this quarry where we are
right now rebellium is perhaps best
known
for the fact that it is quite
controversial in terms of its naming
there's a name for an element it is
really quite a good one
manganese is actually a much more
interesting metal than you might expect
now i understand one of my colleagues
said thinks a bit boring
so at the moment i'm in the office of
professor eric hope
who is one of the country's specialists
in florian chemistry
obviously einsteinium has a slight
resonance for me
because many people think that i look
like einstein fermium it has absolutely
no
use as far as anyone knows except that
it's extremely radioactive
family was an italian physicist
mendelevium which is named after one of
the most important people as far as the
periodic table is concerned which is
dimitri mendeleev
mendeleev has another cause of fame he
is famous in russia
because he was the person who worked out
the standard for the strength of vodka
this is uranium turnings
uranium is the basis of much of
nuclear power the thorium cow
is a sample of thorium-229
they thought it was just waste but then
they suddenly realized this fantastic
application
so here you can see we've got a very
thin foil sample
of dysprosium i've just realized that
erbium
is the most crucial element for the
internet it's soft
silvery quite malleable very reactive
towards oxygen and water
it's a stainless steel container that
has plutonium oxide
so hopefully that stuff will see its way
onto some spacecraft in the mid
2020 time frame this is a really quite
unusual sample from goodfellow and you
see this is sumerium so this is one of
the lanthanides nickel
is element number 28.
two or three days ago i got a letter
it's scandium
i'm going to convince some electrons in
the metal to jump onto the
vanadium
we're going to try and do an experiment
today it's called the gallium beating
heart
indium is a really fascinating material
and we're going to show you why it was
called indium
how you can mold things out of it and
how you can do some reactions
thallium salts are very poisonous
element 113
is the first element to be definitely
synthesized in japan so copenhagen
or caponicium as the discoverers would
prefer to be pronounced
is the latest name to go up on the
periodic table
there were quite nice crystals that you
could see and there was this great lump
of mercury at the bottom but neil had
quite a lot of difficulty getting it out
at the end and it began to melt and so
on it can be very easily overlooked but
actually it's got some really fantastic
uses
the other thing i know about homium is
that at low temperature
it exhibits very strong magnetism
thulium as well as being able to attain
the plus three oxidation state is also
one of those ones which can obtain the
plus
two oxidation state we've since made
four different isotopes
of livermorium they all have tens of
millisecond
half-lives so they're pretty short-lived
so unfortunately i can't show you a
bottle
madame curie was polished though she did
most of her research
if not all of it in paris polonium is
named after poland
tellurium you've never had anything to
do with it nothing to do with in my life
so this is a new one for me
argon can be liquefied
[Music]
krypton can also be used in lasers
the next day i was horrified the xenon
balloon had got small they carried sort
of little glass tubes of radium in their
pockets and were then surprised when
they found burns on their flesh
this is a sample of rubidium it's one of
the alkali metals so it's very very
reactive and
we're going to explore its chemistry now
by by putting this into some water
okay this is the periodic table of the
elements that was used for the
christening of element 111
which was called rendganium okay we're
going to be looking today at copper
copper copper metal copper is an element
which
people are very familiar with so the
aluminium will become oxidized the iron
will become reduced
hopefully we'll generate a lot of molten
iron which should come from the bottom
of the test tube and you can see that
it's so hot it's burnt a hole through
the bottom of that
terracotta flower pot but if we go in
close now brady
germanium is the first element in the
periodic table beginning at hydrogen
that's named after a country brady
thought
that tin was a really boring element but
we've changed his mind
antimony you can see through the bottle
is a really quite nice metallic element
we're going to tell you about the
chemistry of arsenic
the textbooks say that when you dissolve
arsenic
in nitric acid you make a solution the
poisonous oxide
protein was only really discovered
properly in 1918
well after the death of mendelev
actinium
i think is interesting for several
reasons
curium can be used in thermoelectric
generators to produce electricity
so ytterbium it's a rare earth element
was first
identified or first isolated from a
sample of a mineral which was recovered
from this very quarry
european salts are used in
television screens lanthanum is the
first element in the series called the
rare earths they're not terribly rare
cerium is one of only two elements which
if you strike it will make sparks
many people don't think promethium is
very important
including the makers of mai tai there
may be a slight argument
about how you pronounce the name of
element 117.
i would pronounce it tenocine like
iodine and chlorine astatine was known
to be really radioactive iodine is a
beautifully coloured element
it has this beautiful purple colour so
now you can see the reaction is really
going and it's really exothermic
we're forming aluminium tri-iodide lead
is a very soft metal
and it's easily molded into all sorts of
shapes
this is a pot they've finally chosen the
name for element 115
and the name is moscovium okay i've got
a piece of
crystalline bismuth bismuth is
interesting because it is
the heaviest element that is not
radioactive
flory of george nicola which
says dal institute
we're going to tell you about lutetium
we're going to show you some
demonstrations
particularly a terrific red color that
you can get from it
and this is a sample of cadmium metal
i'm not going to touch the cadmium
because we know about some of the issues
of toxicity
this is what we're starting with a
beautiful one kilogram jar of silver
and here you can see
there is sample that is labeled
palladium
if you heat cobalt chloride which is
beautiful red colored crystals
to high temperature you can drive off
the water
and make a sort of purplish powder
presidentium
is a very interesting element it's been
used to enable us to get within one one
thousandth of a degree of absolute zero
okay so gadolinium is smackbang in the
middle of the 4f series
this is i think the first sample of
metallic rhodium
that i've ever held in my hands i'm more
excited by the fact that this
is worth quarter of a million pounds
than by the fact that it's a
thermocouple
so here we have a sample of titanium
wire and upon analysis they were really
really surprised to find that there were
a number of elements including itrium
which existed in a much much higher
abundance on the moon so here i am in
strontium
now you can see i'm on my own i'm not
with the professor or anyone else
but i have managed to find the address
of a local history expert
so i'm going to go and pay him a visit
but with zirconium
i've had one sample which is
big lumps of metal
we're interested in the elements rather
fordium
first of all you can see that rutherford
is smoking in the lab
we're here in the german state of hesse
at the institute gsi
where passion was first made in 1984
i'm here with more platinum than i've
ever seen in my life
people apparently occasionally order
wedding dresses
from here i want to talk to you about
seborgan
they decided that you could not name
an element after a living person but we
urged them to check and see and there
was actually no such rule
at all chromium is a really surprisingly
exciting element
we've had real fun in the lab you're
going to see some quite exciting things
the first laser pointers were red they
didn't use neodymium
and the green ones have become really
quite fashionable but among lecturers
i'm in the coffee room where
element 109 my nerium was named
and borium was the first of these super
heavy elements to be made here in
germany in darmstadt
i'd never seen niobium until recently
the ruthenium is very very finely
divided and if i tip it you can see in
the bottom of the vial
very fine powders element 110
damstartium was discovered here
in darmstadt tantalum is another element
which has become more important in
recent years
today i'm going to tell you some more
about molybdenum wires and show you some
amazing micrograph tungsten is a very
hard and heavy
element it is used in the filament
of light bulbs no this is not a sample
of dubnew
but dubnium like all the elements in
this part of the periodic table
can only be made synthetically one of
the big surprises
of the whole periodic video project for
me
was my actually seeing a sample of
technesium
is going towards the bottom of the the
group two barium
is a heavy element hafnium is i think an
element to watch
rhenium is in the same group as
manganese
but quite surprisingly it was only
discovered in 1925
i should on that account inclined to
call
the metal osmium here is osmium
and he's called this because of the
smell and here
i've got a big piece of iridium this
weighs
3.8 kilos we're in the vault
the bullion vault of the bank of england
i've never seen
so much gold in fact i've never seen so
much of any element
it's very secure we've been through a
whole series of
security checks i'm here in dubna in
russia
at the joint institute of nuclear
research
and i'm in the office of yuri aganessian
after whom
element 118 was named
you